North Korea America is number one excuse
for putting off chores this week you
know I can't do laundry but if the
world's about to erupt into nuclear war
what really is the point
north Korea has clearly been on
everyone's minds this week and I think
you know why
president Franzen North Korea escalate
the war of words lobbying new threats
and sending new tweets North Korea now
accusing the president United States of
pushing the world to float the brink of
nuclear war Wow when Twitter was
invented I bet even they didn't imagine
that it would one day lead us to the
brink of nuclear Armageddon it's like if
the invention of the Furby had led to
the Sudanese Civil War who knew that
that's where it was headed
now tensions have sharply escalated this
week which is a little surprising given
that the world has been dealing with
North Korea's provocative missile tests
for years now just two weeks ago they
were doing this North Korea fires yet
another missile but Pyongyang claims
this one will be able to hit the US
mainland striking cities like Los
Angeles Denver Chicago and possibly even
New York and Boston wait New York I live
in New York this just got real
no I think if anyone is if everyone is
really honest your level of fear over
the North Korea situation is in direct
proportion to whether or not they can
hit the exact place where you live we
filmed this show on 57th Street if you
told me that the blast radius stops at
56th Street I think well I hope nothing
happens but we've still got time before
things get serious
so it is any word properly understanding
what North Korea is currently capable of
because well their missiles may be able
to reach us and they do have nuclear
warheads most experts believe that they
don't yet have the technology to
reliably hit the US mainland
so that is reassuring although on the
other hand a recent Pentagon assessment
did suggest that they could cross that
threshold next year so if a job
interviewer asks you where do you see
yourself in five years time it is now
perfectly acceptable just to scream in
terror into their face look listen this
is clearly a very serious situation
requiring a deft hand and sadly that's
not what it got what career best not
make any more threats to the United
States they will be met with fire and
fury like the world has never seen fire
and fury the only way that that is not
terrifying is if you report it the way
that one newspaper actually did in Maine
saying Trump warns of fire and furry
looks great from for threatening to send
this to North Korea it is a very
different kind of threat now now in
response North Korea announced plans to
fire missiles that would land just off
the coast of the u.s. territory of Guam
which is frightening although not
unprecedented they have made similar
threats before but what is different
this time obviously is that we now have
a president who has the general
temperament of a wet cat and in response
to that Guam threat Trump promptly
doubled down
frankly the people that were questioning
their statement was it too tough maybe
it wasn't tough enough if anything that
statement may not be tough enough
already
well you'll see you'll see yeah we're
going to go with that bomb more
destructive Bamie nuclear bomb why I
don't know who carefully doesn't exist
Sincerely Yours Donald Trump I'm not
writing a letter I'm talking says you
fake news goodbye so tonight we thought
we would are what exactly is North Korea
thinking how did we get into this mess
and what can we possibly do about it and
let's start by trying to understand just
a little bit more about North Korea and
that in itself is difficult it's one of
the most isolated and insular nations on
earth if you know anything about it at
all it's probably just that they have a
wacky totalitarian leader who loves
military parades and Dennis Rodman and
who really didn't like that Seth Rogen
movie about is a fascination and it can
be hard to trust any information about
North Korea because lots of it is
inaccurate for multiple reasons first
there's the outright state propaganda
which glorifies North Korea's leaders
the Kim family just last year we showed
you Western journalists being taken on a
tour of a historic target range where
they learn something suspiciously
impressive about Kim Jong Un's father
comrade Kim Jong is just three bullets
and three off don't god fuels I
they all got Balzac and how old was he
at the time so it's seven year old the
seven year old gunnery bullseye that's
pretty impressive
that's that EVP of someone who really
wants to shut down the conversation she
sounds like a parent building questions
about where babies come from so a stork
brings the baby in who it carries an
8-pound baby through the air in his
mouth in here isn't that dangerous
where does the stalker get the babies
storks they each other so
each other and the baby comes out of the
song vagina don't ask for the truth if
you can't handle it
inaccuracy like that are easy to spot
what is tricky it's a lot of eye
catching Western reporting about North
Korea can be shakily sourced like this
one
the BBC reports all of the men in the
Hermit Kingdom must now sport the same
haircut as the dear leader Kim jong-un
his look was known as the tiny smuggler
haircut not too long ago in the region
but now it will be known as the haircut
every man in North Korea must have lucky
damn here's the thing there is no solid
evidence for that story is true but it
is seductive because it sounds like it
could be it's like if you saw the
headline Trump to NATO I invented
squirrels you'd believe it because it
sounds like something he would have
claimed even though as of this taping he
has not and what while it may not be
true that all men had to get the same
haircut as Kim jong-un Estate TV did run
a series called let us trim our hair in
accordance with the socialist lifestyle
and it's weird when a verifiable truth
is almost as strange as a wild rumor
it's like how the Richard Gere put a
gerbil in his are story
it's completely false but what if the
truth was engaged in consensual mutual
angle play with a chinchilla that was
still be bizarre you wouldn't have to
exaggerate that and sometimes the truth
about life in North Korea can be just as
striking as the urban legends for
instance you may have seen claims online
that every teacher in North Korea is
obligated to play the accordion we could
not confirm that although in trying to
we did discover that North Korea does
love the accordion to a surprising
extent the country is full of them here
is an accordion Factory
here's some school children playing the
accordion here's kim jeong-hoon looking
at an accordion here is an air combat
exercise where the camera pans across
pilots and guess what yep it's a
accordion
but they also have a very popular song
called nothing to envy in the world that
begins with the line the sky is blue my
heart is merry let the sound of
accordions ring and then there is this
video of North Koreans playing the last
song that you would expect yes that is
North Korean accordionist playing take
on me so be that everyone else who plays
the accordion by which I mean exactly
two old French men and one Weird Al
Yankovic and if you think that that is
the most amazing piece of North Korean
pop culture that you're going to see
tonight you are wrong because let me
introduce you to pulgasari a 1985 movie
known as the North Korean Godzilla the
whole thing is incredible but this is
undoubtedly my favorite part
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know why I love that it's relatable
no matter where you're from or what your
religious or political beliefs are at
some point everybody has been about to
decapitate someone and then out of
nowhere a baby monster jumps up and
takes a bite out of your sword it works
because it resonates I'm not soft we're
all having fun when laughing about North
Korea
and it can be very funny but the very
fact that that is true can be extremely
frustrating to journalists to cover it
so it's not an exaggeration and a parody
and you know kind of a freak show which
I think those of us who cover it North
Korea find a little bit distressing
because it's not actually very funny to
the 24-month so the 24 million people
who live there she's right she's
absolutely right
and even when North Korea is objectively
funny like with pulgasari
it has dark undertones because Kim
jong-il got that movie made by abducting
two of South Korea's biggest names in
film and forcing them to make movies for
him for years and you know what they did
eventually escape so I'm going to go
ahead and say and I know this is not
going to be a popular opinion but if
that's what it took to give us that baby
monster scene it was worth it
just my opinion just my opinion but the
underlying truth of North Korea is that
it is a dark place not just figuratively
but literally you can get a sense of how
little development there as being there
when you look at it from space
see that void where there is almost no
likes that's North Korea it looks like a
divorced dad's Christmas tree where he
gave up halfway through hanging the
lights got drunk and fell asleep
watching ten burns baseball and the Kim
family is known for their bone-chilling
cruelty and mismanagement they were
largely responsible for the deaths of
somewhere between six hundred thousand
and two and a half million people during
a famine in the 1990s and we know that
there are large brutal camps where
political dissidents are imprisoned
sometimes alongside their extended
families satellite images show their
scale but for a picture of what they're
really like we can only rely on those
who've been there a mother did what
we're going to Petra
she de la mañana man engine Allium more
my resume and our economy I don't know
why so many amazing young Papageno
quintet in one Palmer Tarot religious
these sketches are the recollections of
other prisoners who've managed to escape
the camps that is truly horrific but the
existence the continued existence of
those camps brings us to a really
important point to understand kim
jeong-hoon is terrified of losing power
and what we love to present him as a
madman many experts believe that his
actions are motivated by rational
self-preservation he has seen leaders
like Saddam Hussein and Muammar Gaddafi
scaled back their nuclear programs only
to be overthrown at you either by the
u.s. or by their own people and die
gruesome deaths and it's true that
dictators generally don't end their
careers like disgraced American
politicians with a stint on Dancing with
the Stars although that would have been
an incredible season so damn that
Foxtrot was a weapon of mass deduction
and lomar you worked hard and it showed
so so kim jeong-hoon
has continued his family's
military-first policy spending huge
amounts of money on what is the fourth
largest military on earth and an
expensive nuclear program in an
impoverished country whose economy has
been estimated to be smaller than that
of Birmingham Alabama and Birmingham is
a small economy their most notable
export is American Idol season five
winner Taylor Hicks not that I am saying
that's a bad thing
so patrol forever so patrol till I
guy so so so how can kim
jeong-hoon justify that spending well he
argues that the huge military is the
only thing staving off imminent invasion
from a host of outsiders and that is
where we come in because the most
dominant and useful villain in North
Korea's narrative is the United State
and it is not like that comes out of
nowhere
we sided with the South during the
Korean War and while many Americans may
have forgotten just how devastating that
war was the North Koreans certainly
haven't they have an entire museum
devoted to American war atrocities and
I'm not saying that there were none but
I don't think anyone quite as
over-the-top as this
giganto polka bands in the last
liberation war during our strategic
retreat the american hyenas occupied the
land of shenzhen they arrested min-jung
sheikh and stabbed her muscles with a
three-pronged spear and sucked her
flowing blood they also took the flesh
from her thighs using a bayonet dipped
it in salt and ate it and in case you're
wondering yes you can buy coasters
depicting that scene in the museum gift
shop but they are $16 which is the real
war crime there and the North Koreans
indoctrination in anti-americanism
starts extremely young as one defector
remembers in math school says dear
ironic ambassador you could chew of them
their harmony America bathrooms list
left to care and as a child I have to
say to American backward and that was my
education holy it is fascinating
when a country's culture seeps even into
their math lessons although it's not
really surprising as a British child our
math questions were if Johnny has two
artifacts and Dinesh has two artifacts
then how many artifacts is Johnny about
to have the odds of course all the
artifact collecting families he come
visit them in the British Museum
whenever they're in town and the notion
that North Korea is working on a bomb
that can kill all the American bastards
is a tremendous source of national pride
there have been stamps depicting
missiles hurtling towards the US Capitol
and a few years ago they produced a
video depicting the destruction of New
York set to the least appropriate song
imaginable
[Music]
yes you heard right that was a karaoke
version of we are the world set to New
York in flames and the last time I saw a
karaoke song with background imagery
that inappropriate was every time I've
ever sung karaoke I don't know what LL
Cool J is doing it has to do with these
two babies in the field of sunflowers
but it's making everybody uncomfortable
so the North Korean regime has been very
careful about presenting a threatening
image of Americans to its people and
some activists have actually been trying
to undermine that by sneaking
information into the country on USB
drives okay I don't tell me that at all
we send various content from stories on
human rights general information on
South Korea to images depicting the
average American or a fictional version
of the average American TV shows like
The Mentalist and desperate housewife
Chung says scenes like this one from
NCIS anything you say can and will be
used against you in a court of law
they show police officers reading
suspects their rights are especially
useful you know what if nothing else we
finally have our answer to the
decade-long question who the is
watching NCIS it turns out if all your
mom friends and the people of North
Korea and if you think about it that is
very dangerous for Kim jong-un because
if people get a sense that the image of
America that he has carefully painted
for them is false he could have huge
problems and when you understand him in
that light as a dictator desperately
hedging against a loss of power it is
possible to understand why all his
recent threats against the United States
have been reckless but in his mind also
rational and that brings us to the key
question here what are we going to do
about this
because on the campaign trail Donald
Trump made it all seem very simple they
said would you speak to the leader of
North Korea I said absolutely why not
why not and they come out drop board
speak to her
who the hell cares I'll speak to anybody
who knows there's a 10 percent or a 20
percent chance that I can talk him out
of those damn nukes cuz who the hell
wants him to have nukes and there's a
chance no no there really isn't
partly because remember Kim jong-un
believes they are critical for his
survival and on top of that Donald Trump
is a shitty negotiator in his short
presidency he has failed to get Mexico
to pay for his stupid wall he's failed
to get a Congress his party controls to
pass a health care bill and even when
his administration does get something
done it way over sells it but when the
White House announced a trade deal with
China has very big news gigantic and
Herculean and one much celebrated
component turned out to be lifting a ban
on beef imports the China had
preliminary agreed to last September so
way to go there Donald what a
very big Herculean deal thanks for you
accept not entirely thanks to you
America is now marginally more able to
export beef again and since taking
office Trump has voiced support for an
even simpler solution China is helping
us possibly or probably with the North
Korean situation okay which is a great
thing right so in the space of 14
seconds there he said the word great
twice he pronounced China with
refillables suggested someone else
should do the work for him and then
threw in a possibly or probably
rendering the whole thing meaningless I
think I may have just hit Trump bingo
and the price that I want is to go drown
in a river
but Trump idea there of convincing China
to exert influence on North Korea is not
inherently crazy China shares an 800
mile border with North Korea and
accounts for as much as 90% of North
Korea's total trade so they do have
significant leverage but some are
skeptical about just what China could or
is willing to do take sanctions at the
UN have tried multiple rounds of
increasingly harsh sanctions but North
Korea has always found easy ways around
them though whoever the heck North Korea
is a 100% state enterprise so these
companies change their names the next
day if they're listed for sanctions that
way the company stays but with different
names whenever there are sanctions if
I'm included in the list my name can be
changed to yeah and that is some pretty
weak enforcement think about it this way
let's say HBO decided they wanted to
cancel this show their hand would be
pretty weak if I was just able to get
around that simply by changing the name
to earlier times but now sorry fans
noggin derful and it is true that China
could increase enforcement of its
actions but they are understandably
worried about where that could lead
what they worried about is if they do
that will the regime collapse what does
that mean millions of refugees pouring
into China possibly a unified Korea that
is then a pro-american country sitting
on their southern border with don't
forget there are 30,000 American troops
in South Korea which would then be on
China's border and by the way 15 nuclear
weapons you know that there are a lot of
problems when you end up saying oh and
by the way
15 nuclear weapons imagine you what a
babysitter when you heard okay you've
got his EpiPen you know about his nut
allergy he needs his inhaler every hour
oh and by the way he has 15 nuclear
weapons now Trump has also been
mentioning military solutions for even
targeted strikes against weapon systems
could get out of hand very fast
North Korea would likely retaliate and
they have an estimated 8,000 pieces of
heavy artillery stationed just north of
the DMZ which is here and that artillery
is capable of reaching Seoul which is
just 40 miles away and is an area with
25 million people so even a non-nuclear
war could have horrific results and
let's just engage in some truly magical
thinking what if you could somehow just
take out kim jeong-hoon well you've
probably got an immediate humanitarian
crisis on your hands as well as a
leaderless country with a power vacuum
and nuclear weapons and as we've learned
from Iraq and Afghanistan when regimes
fall and there is no plan in place that
vacuum can be filled with terrible
things we do not want to find out what
North Korea's Isis would be even just
the phrase North Korea's Isis is
absolutely terrified it's like saying
911s Bill Cosby what would that even be
I hope we never have to find out so
sanctions are no guarantee and military
action could be catastrophic and
diplomacy is going to be extremely
difficult given that you usually need to
have a specific goal in mind and Trump
seems to be making all of this up as he
goes along we are learning stunning new
details about president Trump's
extraordinary fire and fury threat
tonight multiple sources telling CNN the
president ad-libbed those words they
were improvised on the fly but
sake that is just not a good idea as I'm
sure someone has had to say to Wayne
Brady at a funeral more than once now is
not a good time to improvise these are
one word for guest in Wayne Warren more
like a person and look the thing is
that's not a surprise
think down we all assumed that he was
winging it we have become accustomed to
discounting a large percentage of what
comes out of his face but North Korea is
listening to what he says and the people
there have been primed for decades to
believe that America is on the brink of
an invasion just look at their
government's response to his fire and
fury line forget about them the American
commander-in-chief remains stuck at a
Golf Course oblivious to what is
happening and talking about such
nonsense as fire and fury since it is
impossible to have talks of people who
are incapable of rational thought the
strategic armed forces his judge that we
must respond with absolute force hey hey
hey
okay just to be clear the president is
not stuck at a golf course unless the
tart ran out of gas we have to walk in
which case yes the president is very
much stuck at the golf course and may
need to be airlifted out
so here is where we are we have two
nuclear-armed leaders who are accustomed
to issuing empty threats to impress
their own people and they are now
currently goading each other towards
Armageddon which is absolutely
terrifying and I don't really have a
solution to this but part of me would
love the chance just a chance to speak
directly to the North Korean people so
on the off chance that this show is
smuggled over their border on a USB
Drive crammed with NCIS episodes I would
just like to say this hi North Korea you
may be hearing some frightening rhetoric
from our president but if it helps at
all when our president says words he
doesn't necessarily mean what those
words mean it's it's very difficult to
describe to you we're still trying to
wrap our heads around it ourselves it's
really it's our problem except it is now
kind of your problem too but I want to
talk to you about some misconceptions
because we certainly have misconceptions
about you but you should know ideally
that we are not remotely what your state
propaganda implies either we honestly do
not spend our days plotting your
destruction we spend them sharing cat
memes and spinning vigil and getting
furiously angry about a singing boy
barely appearing in our favorite dragon
jar so for what it's worth I would like
to give you the North Korean people and
sense of how America is feeling right
now in a way that you might understand
and enjoy and that is through the
international language of the accordion
and I have some good news and some bad
news there the bad news is I do not play
the accordion the good news is I know
someone who plays it like a
angel ladies and gentlemen and the
people of North Korea please welcome mr.
Weird Al
[Applause]
[Music]
annihilator finca had a chance
that's a tenant you don't open you got a
crapping our collective hands
may I suggest being a down a notch or
two
we're not exactly sure why Harrell pet
said that the program we may be Superman
and like us is you gotta know as I bet
we're mostly harmless even people hey
we're really not so bad my point is
please on the Oslo Soria right now we're
all a little tense believe me please
don't hate you frankly can read only
something that much about you know event
now you might call a fluffy dog but
that's metaphor not very Apple we're
just a bunch of simple fridges bin and
Ruby door probably could find your
country on a map
no we're not delegate or cannibal for me
he just a really really really bothers
them so I think Oh it'd be best if you
knock off a little dance
sojourn us and defender Wallace wife and
right are tender don't don't start
Armageddon or bitch'll to West to think
this for a moment please
now why would Obama a celebrity why did
the world was until Tom Hanks nobody
liked
so please don't discuss or for Mia now a
serious through a nine a remember we're
not evil but I'm on tears no matter what
[Music]
[Applause]